RICK HARRISON: Is
there something
wrong with the AC in here?
AUSTIN RUSSELL: The AC's fine.
RICK HARRISON: It's
hot in here, it's warm.
You having hot flashes?
I'm not having hot flashes.
Maybe you're going
through male menopause.
There's no such thing
as male menopause.
COREY HARRISON: No, there's
male menopause, dude.
Male menopause is said to
be the result of gradual drop
in testosterone.
OK, my testosterone is fine.
I am not going
through menopause.
COREY HARRISON: What are
some of the symptoms of this?
Night sweats in men?
AUSTIN RUSSELL: Yep.
I don't night sweat.
AUSTIN RUSSELL: That's
not what I hear.
COREY HARRISON: Depression?
You know, one of the
biggest signs of depression
is being angry all the time.
That's definitely you.
COREY HARRISON: Loss of hair.
Then you might have had
menopause for like, 10 years.
He might be the
(LAUGHING) longest
known case of menopause.
[music playing]
[dog barking]
[cannon fire]
RICK HARRISON: Hey, guys,
how do you like the swords
I just bought?
All from the Napoleonic era.
COREY HARRISON: I
know who Napoleon is.
He's your hero.
RICK HARRISON: Why
would he be my hero?
COREY HARRISON:
You're both short.
You both want to be dictators.
You guys are just haters.
I mean, I could
win a Nobel Prize,
and you guys would sit
around say it's not shiny.
What could you possibly
ever win a Nobel Prize in?
I don't think I'll
ever win a Nobel Prize.
I'm just using it as
an example that if I--
Who uses that as an
example for something--
if I won a Nobel Prize.
That's like where your mind is.
That's what you
think of yourself.
This is why I--
You have considered the
fact that you could possibly
win a Nobel Prize one day.
[music playing]
Oh, this kid was just
trying to sell me an old
16-millimeter movie camera.
It's garbage, isn't it?
RICK HARRISON: Well, sort
of, but you know there's
still cool things about film.
COREY HARRISON: Like what?
Give me an example.
Yeah.
Well, like depth of
field, color reproduction,
like really high
resolution photos.
I can do more
on your cell phone
than you can with one
of those old cameras.
RICK HARRISON:
What are you doing?
AUSTIN RUSSELL: I'm showing you
the resolution my phone gets.
I know you look mad, (LAUGHING)
but that's how you always look.
Digital is great, it's
faster, it's more convenient.
But there's a few things with
film you can't reproduce.
It's faster, it's more
convenient, it's better,
but I'm old and I like film.
COREY HARRISON: Is this one of
those things like the old man
used to go through, that just
because like you're starting
to see stuff from your
past become useless,
you're afraid you're
going to be useless?
You're not going to replace
me like they replaced film,
are you?
[music playing]
[wolf whistle]
RICK HARRISON: I just
tried to buy a really
early Jim Henson vinyl puppet.
AUSTIN RUSSELL: Like Jim Henson
from the Muppets and all that?
RICK HARRISON: Yeah.
COREY HARRISON: You know,
if you were a Muppet,
you'd definitely be
one of the old guys
up top in the
balcony complaining
and whining about everything.
RICK HARRISON: Actually,
I think if I was a Muppet,
I would be like Sam the Eagle.
COREY HARRISON: Was
he a bald eagle?
RICK HARRISON: Yes.
Then that's the only thing you
have to do with Sam the Eagle.
[music playing]
RICK HARRISON: On
the weekends, I
think it's just sort
of a waste of time
to watch TV for 14 hours.
COREY HARRISON: You binge
on stuff all the time, Dad.
But that's me binging in my
garage working on something,
or reading a book, or something
like that, something--
What's the difference
between binge watching
TV and binge reading a book?
Well, you actually
learn something.
You see, you get
more out of a book.
Rick, you like to binge argue.
RICK HARRISON: I don't
like to binge argue.
You guys turn it into arguments.
AUSTIN RUSSELL: No you like
to binge argue, for sure.
And I bet one of your
three wives could agree.
[sighing]
[laughter]